Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
C’est de la vraie mousse.
Ça me rassure.
Bonsoir à tous, bonsoir à toutes.
Avant de parler de forêt,
je vais parler de mon fils Jean.
J’aurais aimé qu’il soit là,
mais étant responsable,
il est au lit, demain, il a école -
tout ça.
Comme tout bon parent,
j’essaye de lui transmettre des valeurs.
J'essaye de le défouler aussi,
surtout à cinq ans et demi.
C’est compliqué d’arriver
à le défouler tout le temps.
On essaye de faire du sport dehors, de
profiter des beaux volcans d’Auvergne.
Et depuis deux ans,
je lui apprends à faire du ski.
Et là, j’ai un petit problème
de conscience :
faire du ski en moyenne montagne,
j’ai un peu l’impression de lui faire
goûter un super bonbon délicieux -
vous voyez comme ça -
et au moment où il croque dedans,
je le lui enlève.
Je pense que dans quelques années, le ski
en moyenne montagne, ce sera ponctuel.
Je me dis : « Qu’est-ce que je fais ? »
Ça fait dix ans avec Sandra,
mon épouse, la mère de Jean,
qu’on est en dissonance entre les valeurs
qu’on essaye de transmettre à notre fils
et ce qu'on fait dans notre travail.
Dix ans dans le commerce,
dans le tourisme.
On s’est dit : « On arrête
et on part sur autre chose. »
Cette autre chose,
c’est un parc de loisirs écocitoyen.
Très compliqué : qu’est-ce qu’on met
dedans ? Comment on fait ?
Dès qu’on parle de tourisme,
il y a un impact.
Si on n’en veut pas,
on ne fait pas de tourisme.
On est dans une région volcanique
où il y en a énormément.
Peut-on proposer quelque chose de
différent qui tente de limiter l’impact ?
À la base, on est parti sur cinq valeurs.
On a construit un puzzle
autour de ces cinq valeurs.
Une valeur d’éco-responsabilité :
il faut qu’on respecte le lieu où on est.
Une forêt, on ne touche pas aux arbres,
ni au sol, on ne fait pas de tranchée,
pas de terrassement.
On pose des terrasses au sol ;
en fin de saison, on les retire.
On est sur de la sobriété
en termes d’activités.
On n’amène pas des milliers de personnes
à la minute, on respecte ce terrain.
Deuxième valeur : on est
sur le côté coopératif.
On essaye de tout faire ensemble,
même dans nos activités.
On propose des activités
où le public doit coopérer.
On n’est pas là à se tirer dans les
pattes, à essayer de battre l’autre.
On fait ensemble.
Troisième valeur :
le côté intergénérationnel.
on veut que tout le monde s’amuse,
on veut créer du lien.
Quatrième valeur : on veut
un côté pédagogique, bien sûr.
Si, en plus de s’amuser, on pouvait
passer un message bienveillant -
pas moralisateur, attention -
qui plante des graines dans la tête
de nos enfants, de vos enfants.
on aurait gagné.
La cinquième valeur :
c’est un parc de loisirs,
il faut que ce soit ludique.
Aujourd’hui, on a dessiné
le contour de ce puzzle.
On a ouvert il y a deux ans
un site été sur le lac d’Aydat,
un site hiver sur la station du Mont-Dore.
Deux sites pour suivre
les flux touristiques.
On ne va pas créer un flux
touristique lié à notre activité,
on va là où il y a déjà le public.
On est autonome en énergie - centrale
solaire, on a des toilettes sèches.
On utilise énormément
de matériaux de seconde main,
typiquement une corde d’escalade réformée
qui sert à baliser notre terrain de jeu.
Les activités qu’on propose -
on en a parlé -
c’est de l’escape game,
du laser game en forêt.
On a une zone de spectacles, concerts,
projections de films, événementiel.
On est en train de tout assembler
petit à petit.
Le puzzle est encore long.
On a fait le contour,
tout le remplissage est à faire.
On va le faire ensemble pour Jean,
pour vos enfants,
pour aller vers un tourisme plus durable,
responsable et socialement innovant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)